in court has just announced its decision  and it shows that the Prime Minister has  acted wrongly in shutting down  Parliament it demonstrates it  demonstrates a contempt for democracy  and an abuse of power by him and the  supreme court therefore passes the  passes the baton to the speaker to  recall Parliament I will be in touch  immediately to demand that Parliament is  recalled so that we can question that  Prime Minister  demand that he obeys the law that's been  passed by Parliament and recognize that  our Parliament is elected by our people  to hold our government to account a  Labour government would want to be held  to account  we wouldn't bypass democracy and I  invite Boris Johnson in the historic  words to consider his position  and become and become thee and become I  got that message and become the shortest  serving Prime Minister has ever been